Have you ever noticed cars look like they
have faces?
Is that intentional?
Spoiler: Yes… hehe… spoiler…
Get it, it’s a car joke.
Ok just roll the intro.
Hi petrol heads, Julian in for DNews.
Humans have a tendency to see faces in everyday
objects.
But Elvis doesn’t keep showing up on your
toast because the king is haunting your cuisinart,
it’s because of a phenomenon called pareidolia.
This false pattern recognition, along with
our tendency to anthropomorphize things, means
we often see faces on cars, and actually assign
them emotions and expressions.
in 2008 a study asked 40 people to rate the
traits of 38 different passenger cars.
Almost everybody agreed on which cars had
which traits.
When asked which cars they preferred, people
overwhelmingly liked cars that were low and
wide, with angled headlights and wide grills.
These were the cars that were ranked as aggressive
and powerful.
More recent studies have looked at what parts
of the brain were active when looking at the
fronts of cars.
A 2011 study examined car expert’s brains
with an fMRI and discovered when they looked
at pictures of faces and cars, the part of
the brain they use for processing faces called
the Fusiform Face Area, lit up.
That study’s use of experts raised the question
that maybe we start to use our FFA for everyday
objects only after we spend a lot of time
around them.
So a study published December 17th took 20
random adults with no interest in cars and
put them in an fMRI while showing them pictures
of cars.
The results showed the subjects used their
FFAs when looking at cars.
But the parts of the brain that are linked
to thinking about the mental states of others,
the temporoparietal junction and medial prefrontal
cortex, were not activated.
So they saw faces in cars but they didn’t
think of the cars as having emotions.
Which must make me weird, because I definitely
have a love affair with my car.
A few of you who watch Arrested Development
may be wondering if people with face blindness
have trouble distinguishing cars.
As it turns out, yes, a common symptom of
prosopagnosia, or face-blindness, is that
cars all just look like blocks on wheels.
Car makers are completely aware of pareidolia
when they design a car, and they tend to give
their sportier models more aggressive faces.
People also interpret faces and expressions
differently from culture to culture, and it’s
part of the reason some manufacturers alter
or don’t even offer certain models in different
places.
So we may be great at spotting faces, but
for some reason we suck at drawing them.
Trace explains that reason over here.
I’m sure we’ve got some gear heads out
there.
What’s the Prettiest car… in the world?
Tell us in the comments and I’ll see you
next time on DNews.